this is a tributary that feeds the grand
rivers that sustain the amazon forest
just look at these pictures
and think about that
because they are not only destroying
trees here they're poisoning rivers too
for joe farah a local campaigning to
save the waterways of manaus it is
heartbreaking you will not see it
it's just terrible i was born here i
used to swim in this river he told me
it's not only what you see here that's
so depressing it's what you smell it's
industrial waste chemicals and human
sewage flowing through here
this is what man is doing to one of the
greatest and most important rainforests
in the world
much of the pollution is from
uncontrolled housing settlements this
entire area was rainforest just 20 years
ago
most of the 148 small rivers that cross
the city are little more than channels
of human waste
they are dying
on their banks i found the desperately
poor trying to exist amid hopelessness
and disease
understandably for people like mother
and daughter rosa and gaisa it is daily
survival they care about not the fate of
the rainforest or fears of climate
change
all i know is every day here is worse
because the government won't help us
says rosa
marcus castro a professor of urban
geography here says it's too easy to
blame the poor problem
the problem here is there is such
inequality and no proper planning he
says so they have no
choice he thinks rather look to a
government that day by day is allowing
development to eat into the rainforest
river campaigner joe farah is not
prepared to let the rivers here die
in the forest on the edge of the city he
and his team are planting new trees on
the banks of a river he's determined to
preserve my first tree here
regeneration and regrowth that is badly
needed here
and below them pure water running as it
should do